Here the sword uses AI to learn from an opponent's
attacks so I have to get attacked first no no the
sword has already seen blade and loved it you'll
be fine welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
will be my full Rick and Morty season 6 episode
9 video there are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and Cameo scenes some of them were a little bit
more obvious than others we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen
it yet we'll start at the beginning work our
way through shot by shot talking about Easter
eggs and WTF moments as we go along starting
with the episode title A Rick and King mortar's
more which is a reference to the movie a kid in
King Arthur's Court and Rick saving Morty when
he becomes king of the order of the sun there
were some surprisingly big celebrity cameos Jack
Black played lithdor Daniel Radcliffe played this
character here the wizard reference he made when
he was talking about Rick obviously a reference to
Harry Potter I beg your pardon wizard the Knights
of the sun protect the solar scepter around which
Even This World Turns which is actually super
meta in and of itself like Jack Black plays a
lot of animated characters so it's not unusual for
him to voice a character but the whole thing with
Daniel Radcliffe is that back when they did the
live action Rick and Morty promos with Christopher
because Rick and Morty started very literally as
a parody of the Doc Brown Marty McFly relationship
and Back to the Future when they did those promos
initially they wanted Daniel Radcliffe to play
their version of Morty but they felt like that
was too much like being Daniel Radcliffe would
take people out of the bit because they'd only be
thinking about Daniel Radcliffe Harry Potter not
about Morty in a couple years ago when they were
promoting Rick and Morty season 4 Daniel Radcliffe
was asked about this and he said he would love to
be on the show and kind of made this joke about
forcing his way on the show like it's legally
binding you have to cast me as a character on
the show now which they have now done so I just
pitched you to Dan Harmon and Justin Roiland and
they now want you on the show thank you very much
that's really kind of you and I want them to know
that they don't have to feel obliged because they
were on camera no they're excited that would be
crazy cool I would if they have any wrong thank
you genuinely thank you go to the writer's room
you can be part of it and then you can have a
character in the show that would be insane I
would love to do that because they said it it
means it's legally binding we have footage of
you you're all my witness uh yeah okay then I will
try and make this happen thank you very much the
orbit with the restaurant on the asteroid is a bit
of a Spaceballs meets Star Wars and Green Lantern
reference the letters on the building here seem
like a reference to aurebesh which is the common
language of Star Wars they're this big joke about
Morty being super into the sanctity Injustice of
the food line believing in it but Rick calls them
out saying that it's all fake which he winds up
being correct about later because the line winds
up being a creation of the food stall itself just
to pump up their business which itself is part of
the theme of the episode people believing in fake
ideas fake religions and the joke here is that
Morty is so Noble in his desire to wait in line
that he deserves to become a knight of Justice of
the night of the sun here in their culture this
is where you start to get to the Jedi Knight Star
Wars and Green Lantern references like they are a
group of space Knights wielding swords like Jedi
Knights and their lightsabers the other night here
claims that this is how he became one of their
order like a similar type of deal his new name
is Sir mortaniel but that winds up being a bit so
that his name will fit in the song they sing for
everyone that comes to their Planet like that was
part of the joke is that oh we had to change your
name so that it would work with the regular song
that they give to everybody the whole thing with
the previous person dying and giving him the
power is the Green Lantern reference like the
Green Lantern ring Hal Jordan getting the ring
and then being taken back to their home planet
on owa by its power like I said Rick calling
out the false line the false idea the false
sanctity of the line is meant to be part of the
episode's dig at organized religions or occults
they have a big joke about them being Immortal
but still being able to die like oh we can die
we just don't have to throughout the episode they
call out a bunch of fantasy science fiction genre
tropes like they talk about vampires immortality
and being bored from it the big butt here and it
is a really big one is that they have to cut their
dicks off in order to get this power Rick makes a
science joke which is more like a Thor reference
they treat power like a magical thing even though
this medieval looking Asgardian culture is really
just Advanced science that most people don't
understand except for Rick the June bug reference
is a term of endearment that was used in the
American South historically just meaning cute girl
they make another blade movie reference when Rick
gives him the AI powered sword that learns from
fights and it's seen the blade movie itself and
enjoyed it the previous blade joke was during
season five when they saw an alternate reality
where both he and Morty were versions of blade in
the parody of the opening scene of the movie where
he takes everyone down in the club Morty is forced
to become their King when he defeats the previous
one long time fantasy science fiction troper after
you kill someone you have to replace them Rick
makes another blade reference to Deacon Frost
the villain of the movie they make a joke about
the show itself like Rick calls out a Trope
of the Rick and Morty TV show wherein Morty
does something stupid against Rick's advice and
then Rick saves him and berates him for it they
just had an episode about how meta the show gets
and there were several meta fourth wall breaking
moments in this episode Rick breaks the fourth
wall again saying he's going to be more agreeable
for at least one episode or one Adventure
because sometimes they have multiple adventures
in episodes love how cheery the knights are in
nonchalant because they destroy the neighbor's
house when they show up to see Morty without
even addressing it you notice that space Beth
is visiting them again she's been around a lot
this season sometimes only for moments like this
like literally she's just sitting at the dinner
table nodding and agreeing with stuff I think
that's kind of the implication that her mother is
still secretly having that low-grade relationship
with her on the DL Morty tries to disprove their
entire religion using sixth grade science like
any common grade schooler would learn just how
the solar system works just in general people
choosing to disbelieve common science even though
it was proven a long time ago like how dumb can
people be turns out pretty dumb summer makes an
Entourage joke the whole joke with Rick and Morty
being supportive of each other in the episode
is that it leads to the utter destruction of the
entire solar system like that's why they can't
be that supportive of each other otherwise it
leads to complete chaos it's almost like they're
joking that Rick is being so mean all the time
to everyone because he's actually saving them
if he were supportive of them it would lead to
situations like this like the show justifying Rick
being so mad at everyone all the time no no he's
not actually mad at everyone he's just saving all
them pretending to be mad they make a couple Big
Star Trek references the medieval neutral zone
is a reference to Star Trek's Romulan neutral
zone the bit about everyone in the solar system
descending from a common galaxy-wide ancestor
is another Star Trek reference there was a
Next Generation episode where all the major
races found out that they had a common ancestor
in this ancient progenitor race Rick calls out
Pluto saying that it's like the Jerry of planets
it's a the lamest planet in the solar system the
spacesuits they're wearing are the same ones
that they wore back in the time traveling snake
episode all the different colors of the races
are Green Lantern references to the different
Lantern corps like the Green Lanterns the Red
Lanterns yellow blue lanterns Violet and so
on Morty getting confused with all the new tropes
they're introducing like the soothsayer lady with
the bones that are super accurate saying that he's
not going to take time to read all the books it's
just a Game of Thrones reference like I don't have
time to read all the Song of Ice and Fire books
canonically now Santa is the ruler of Earth like
he's the representative on the Council of Earth
Neptune shows up but it's like the Roman version
of Neptune then when they have that huge Montage
of them battling it out killing each other to gain
rulership of the solar system in the scepter Rick
calls it solar War one that's kind of a Star Wars
reference and they play Pink Floyd's Goodbye Blue
Skies song which I think is the first time that
Rick and Morty has used a Pink Floyd song most of
the time the music that they use on Rick and Morty
is original songs that they write for each episode
when they go through the larger Montage of all
the alien races fighting each other the bit with
the rising hands grabbing the scepter poking her
eyes out is a Three Stooges joke Rick making the
joke about the Amish destroying the solar system
by giving them nukes is a joke about all the
different alien races being super low Tech like
them using all the advanced Tech now suddenly
leads to the destruction of the entire solar
system we also find out that Rick's capable of
defending the entire planet with this technology
which I think is new a lot of times in episodes
Rick typically has whatever kind of Technology
he needs in order to complete whatever bit the
episode is performing sometimes the show happens
that way like they write the bit then they create
the technology that Rick needs to pull the bit
off they break the fourth wall again when they
call out the jumping universes bit Rick saying
that the episode is more about them trying to
commit to something rather than bail at the
sign of trouble when Morty references the vat
of acid episode that's not a fourth wall break
though that's him just referencing the adventure
that they previously had that took place during
during that episode it wasn't him referencing
the fact that that was an episode of the show
in general so it's one of those things in this
episode where Rick still understands that he's
a fictional character inside a TV show but Morty
does not despite everything that's happened in
the previous episodes they came pretty close
in a previous episode where Morty's like wait
a minute intro where did the music come from
are we in an actual episode The reason why he
doesn't understand that they're in a TV show
is because when that happened Rick is like no no
forget about that that's all nonsense don't think
about it so Morty still believes that everything
that's happening to them is real they reference
clone Beth again when Morty thinks that Rick
is being supportive of it means he's fake like
he's a robot rig the robot in a family reference
is to the robot Morty in summer he created back
during season three all right engaged no yes
bypassing override I am alive the way he uses
the reference though makes it sound like some of
the family are still robots so let me know in the
comments which of the family members you think
is a robot right now then turns out the Knight
who really wanted drugs definitely found them
as did the rest of the group partake in it they
make a bunch of references to bands and drugs like
Mr Brownstone is a Guns and Roses song reference
which itself in that song was a reference to
drugs this one makes a Motley Crew reference
both of those bands in real life have had lots
of problems with drug addiction then they end
the episode with a whole bit about Morty's dong
having to cut it off Rick creating a fake one for
him a bunch of fail-saves that just goes on and
on and on like a bit within a bit within a bit
when they end the galactic War they have a bunch
of jokes about the knights having super advanced
technology but being weirdly old-timey like all
the Martian Knights here are lying with limbs cut
off and none of them replace them even though they
have this Advanced Med Bay all the groups destroy
their Advanced Tech all the ships their weapons
and start using primitive Tech again returning
to the old ways literally and metaphorically and
they have that whole bit that just goes on about
Morty verifying that he cut his dong off for real
the stump and the peace between the Spheres is
another dick and balls joke like the planetary
spheres and the dick between them love that the
ceremonial shears look like they're super Rusty no
one's bothered to clean them polish them sharpen
them sanitize them for that matter in the eons
that they've been used the other joke here with
the successive different verification devices is
it the final one is the soothsay or woman with the
bones because the whole bit earlier was that the
bones were super accurate detecting his witchcraft
dong which itself is green with a little witch's
hat on it they get a little bit silly with the
end of the episode too with this whole joke about
Rick creating technology to make them telepathic
like Wireless communication technology using
their thoughts but only using it to tell him to
run for like a brief second and then say oh no
we don't need it anymore they go out in a very
thumb and Louise kind of way pretending like
they killed each other which is immortalized
in stained glass revealing that they did think
that he actually cut his dong off because it was
never verified to be true that he didn't you could
call that another joke about organized religion
like well if you can't disprove something that
doesn't mean that it's not true the whole thing
about them hiding beneath a vat of fake sun
is another callback to the vadive acid episode
in bookending the whole thing with the idea that
the guy really wanted to keep his dong like I'm so
happy that we don't have to cut them off anymore
R.I.P just going to pretend like you're dead no
big deal the other thing going on in this final
moment here too is that it's sort of the show
calling out the Trope of this contrived moment
like they didn't actually need to come back to
verify what happened Rick could have used this
technology to find out whether or not it worked
they only came back so that they could literally
have this particular joke about the alien finding
them the whole post credit scene is just a joke
following up on the hot dog food vendor because
the hot dogs are meant to be alien creatures
that are alive shutting down the booth and
turning into this big Law and Order type of bit
about a trafficking ring eventually freeing them
to their home calling out his own death when
he thinks the bird would have killed them but
a giant one carries him off instead there are a
couple moments when the episode was all over the
place and they got a little bit silly but it was
pretty solid and I did like the Daniel Radcliffe
actually showed up to do a cameo and Jack Black
as well let me know in the comments though who
was your favorite Cameo scene like do you think
Jack Black was funnier or Daniel Radcliffe with
all the drug stuff of big reminder that next
week's episode episode 10 is the season 6 finale
they're already been working on season 8 I think
so I'm assuming that season 7 will drop some time
either next year around the same time or by the
summer I'll talk a little bit more about season
7 during my finale video next week make sure you
enable alerts from my channel so you don't miss
that I'll post it as soon as they release it this
past week was like trailer fest because of Brazil
Comic-Con CCXP so I'll try to get as many of
those out as soon as possible everyone click
here for my Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer
video and click here for my new trailer for The
Boys gen V thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!